so some have speculated that this is the
great IRA Miyazaki's final film I went
into this film emotional because of this
like I hadn't even started yet and I was
already like no the wind rises is
directed by Hayao Miyazaki who if you
don't know is pretty much the Steven
Spielberg of Japan the Christopher Nolan
of Japan the Alfred Hitchcock of
animation however you want to look at
him this guy is in my opinion the
greatest living director of animation
not just in Japan in the entire world
this guy is a genius who you haven't
seen films like my neighbor totoro or
spirited away or Princess Mononoke this
guy knows how to make an incredible
animated film and he's made countless
films filled with wonderment and awe
films like Howl's Moving Castle or the
castle on the sky or Kiki's Delivery
Service this guy knows what he's doing
and the wind rises' is just another
notch in his belt this is a much more
realistic film than what he generally
does most of his films are usually very
fantastical this one is very realistic
about a guy ever since youth who has
dreamed of building airplanes that's all
he thinks about the film opens with him
as a child then we see him dreaming and
envisioning these grand creations that
he wants to be a part of then later cuts
to him being an adult he's in a
university he's learning how to do all
these things he's looking at everything
in a different way he'll look at a
fishbone and see the curve of a fishbone
and then immediately think wow this
should be involved in some way in my
design for an airplane and that's one of
the things this film captures perfectly
in my opinion that is when you are a
child and as you grow older maintaining
a dream having that dream and always
envisioning it as you go about your
daily life you see your dream and other
things like I can tell you that's true
because ever since I was a kid I have
always wanted to be involved in movies
or filmmaking in some way shape or form
when I look at things sometimes I do
actually see it in like a sixteen by
nine frame I can't turn that part of me
off and that is the artistic standpoint
of this main character when he looks at
things he sees how things could be
included in the making and designing of
an aircraft and that is why this film
perfectly captures the awe and Wonder
Minh of the
of a child and then the later vision of
an adult trying to maintain this dream
that he's had his entire life there's a
romance in the film that I thought was
beautifully handled extremely sweet and
also very realistic especially for its
time period because this takes place
during World War two and there's always
that air over these characters heads of
am i creating planes or things that are
going to be used in war and most of
these characters they just want to build
planes because they're so into that and
they really want to be part of that
they're not actually thinking about any
type of political agenda and that's
where this movie doesn't come off that
way either this movie never goes yay
America or yay Japan it never has any
type of political thoughts to give us as
an audience it is purely telling us a
beautiful story of someone who has a
dream and it shows the awe and Wonder
Minh of being able to maintain and
harness that dream along with a very
beautiful romance it goes without saying
the artwork in this film is magnificent
I think this is one of his best films it
is such a joy to see an animated film
for adults that kids can also enjoy but
this is mainly for adults to enjoy
because this is very realistic and has
some disturbing images in there and some
images of war that would definitely
stick with you if you were a kid I think
this film is a beautiful work of art if
it is his last film I am deeply saddened
by that but I do think it is a good film
to go out on it is a masterpiece of
animation in my opinion I'm gonna give
the wind rises' and a simile because
there's a little bit of pacing issues in
there where a couple scenes felt like
they didn't actually have to be there
there could have been removed that could
have made the film a little bit more
tight guys if you're a fan of animation
or anime or even just good filmmaking
check out the wind rises it expanded
this weekend I strongly suggest it as
always guys thanks so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
you
[Music]